she's a skinny legend i'll tell you that
much that and that is also just like
way too much bronzer or something
happening there what's on my face there
oh you can't see it just kidding
wow this is the world wide web
[Music]
the following presentation was created
by wired we've quantified your digital
footprint so that you can see the impact
you've had on the internet i'm
horrified let's do it
this is what happens when you google
lily singh they're gonna say did you
mean l-i-l-y i'm sure
all right let's see it 18 million 200.
i love this i there's that many results
subtle flex okay
catch this in my instagram bio as soon
as i get home according to google people
also search for these five other people
oh okay here we go can you guess all
five before we reveal them
show me liza koshy show me priyanka
chopra honestly i want to put it past
the internet people probably also think
i look like hussein minaj so i wouldn't
put that there too
would jimmy fallon be there just because
of late night vibes carson daly because
of late night visit those are my five
guesses
oh yeah my sister my real family i
forgot completely about your existence
wow okay tina she's so beautiful there
it is
eliza's adorable you sif oh okay drama
tea fine sure serve gabby okay a
youtuber okay got it got it
calling interesting i like this i'm
happy this is a good group of people
i i respect this i appreciate it one
section that comes up is people also ask
can you answer these questions let's do
it there's lily sing a billionaire
if i was a billionaire okay do you think
that i would be wearing this outfit that
i completely rented that i'm also going
to wear for six other videos today no
i'd be wearing diamonds pure diamonds
okay
i'm not a billionaire by no means not
even close why is lily
why is lily sing so famous okay first of
all mom i told you to stop
using google in searching these things
okay it's because i'm funny and talented
mostly because of my hair though let's
be real i have fabulous hair and that's
probably why i'm famous
did lily sing dating the rock i did not
dating the rock i
am only mentoring with the rock
friendship with the rock the dating with
the rock has not happened
i would be lying if i said this question
to make me pee a little but it is not
true i'm not dating up the rock
is lily seeing a vegetarian this thing
is a vegetarian i've been vegetarian for
about
12 years and 100 of the time people come
to me and they go
is it because you're of the religion and
no no it's not i just
it's my personal choice most people in
my family do eat meat
it's my own thing but i still love
cheese
according to google people also search
for these five other shows
movies can i guess all five other shows
movies
fahrenheit 451 maybe bad moms
liza on demand
ice age collision course and i'm going
to say
new girl because people don't know the
difference hit me
oh right my own movie forgot that
happened
not gonna lie fahrenheit forfeit hey
okay what else oh right i was also in
that movie totally forgot that happened
all right it was also in that wow i've
done things
is my imdb popping and i don't even know
it yes i have made cameos in these
in these movies minus the one that is
about me that makes a lot the thing is
they're such small
cameos so do they really count
questionable like my mom watched all of
these movies and then after watching
them she was like i thought you were in
it and i said i was
this is a google trends graph of lilly
singh searched over time can you explain
each labeled point
am i getting less famous i see a spike
that's kind of cute okay let's talk
about this
a 2015 i'm going to say is when i went
on my world's tour trip to unicorn
island just kidding it's not that
it's people magazine includes lily sing
on their annual ones to watch list
for real that had a spike huh
i wouldn't have thought that this is
great for me to know cat i want you guys
to know my publicist is on this call
this is gonna come all back to bite me
did you see the graph did you see the
list okay what's b should we okay
so what is it january february march
april may june july july
2016. i i think i released a trip to
unicorn island the documentary in 2016.
didn't i is that why that's there
one two teen choice awards and how to be
a youtube star featuring the rock
uploaded
dang wow is this to say that the things
i'm doing in my personal life like my
projects mean nothing
interesting see january february march
march 2019
2019 2020 right now carry the one maybe
my show
a little late releasing was announced
nbc announces that we also knew late
night talk to a little later thing hey
okay which has to mean with my deductive
reasoning that d
is when my show premiered literally
losing premieres on nbc
wow i would not have guessed any of
these things the last two may be the
first two though
also can we just talk about how from
2016 to 2019 i
died apparently and no one cared about
me as far as i'm concerned i tried my
best
so google trends also
breaks down interest by sub-region can
you guess the top three american cities
interested in releasing since 2014.
i'm going to say new york los angeles
maybe chicago
i don't even know what this is yonkers
is that a place i'm a canadian is that a
place
what it's oh so it's okay cool fine
san jose new york got it so i was close
new york and i have a
interest an interesting relationship
it's a love-hate relationship
any time my life has been disastrous
it's happened in new york
one time i was strolling down the street
i
looked at myself on a billboard i was on
a billboard and as a joke i said to
someone like oh my god that girl on that
billboard and a kid do not
the person looked at the billboard and
said that girl needs to cut her hair
not realizing i was the person and the
second interaction i had was
i was walking down the street and one of
the entertainers came up to me and said
do you want me to perform for you i
think he was dressed up as elf or
something i said no we're okay we're in
a russia we're
heading somewhere he's like oh dude
you're not like american or north
american music and i said i am north
american and i kid you not he looked at
me he goes
no you're not oh we're having attacked
here attacked
this literally it happened so i just had
a little bit of a love-hate
relationship with new york a little bit
per google image search here are some
other words associated with lily singh
can you explain them super win make
sense okay this yes this was my name on
youtube that is no longer my name
because we're not trying to get sued for
a million dollars
but that makes a lot of sense simple
interesting
are people using this are they printing
them out ooh can i sue people for a
million dollars
so i did not invent honesty hour i did
not invent
this this is actually pretty common in
scarborough
so maybe that logo i created but i don't
want to take credit for the hand sign
that is a scar bro thing i love
that i love that that's one of the words
this is one of the things i pride myself
on is i
really really like how people tell me
after watching your videos or your vlogs
i feel like working harder and i really
pick up on your work ethic
that is a great legacy i really love
that it says hustle
okay there it is i wrote a book called
how to be a boss and i was wondering
i was like oh my god it took a full year
to write nowhere in the google search
but
there it is boss we love that i don't
know if i came up with the spelling of
boss
boss is a pretty popular slang term at
least where i am from and where i grew
up people used to say
baus i do think that i used it very well
in terms of like
workplace etiquette and work ethic so
i would like to say that that's more my
brand that i coined
tattoo interesting i would not have
thought that either i do have one
two three four five six tattoos i think
it's crazy how easy you forget about
those first one you're like
sex when you're like put it on my face
got my wrists i got my hand my tattoo on
this side i got live on my late night
show
that might be another reason as well
it's a tribute to toronto however
sometimes you'll make fun of me because
if you look at it it also kind of looks
like the footprints of big bird
my dad character okay are we saying that
manjeet is there but bharamjit is not
hmm my dad's name is not majith in real
life but my dad character's name anjeet
my mom characters named bottomjeet i
always thought that people actually
liked bottom youth a little bit better
because i get way more video requests
about her and comments about her
but it's interesting to see that manjit
is up here it's probably because he's
mad
sexy like is that twisted when sorting
on getty images by most popular this is
one of the top results
do you remember when and where this was
taken show me
really poor quoi i'm so
shook this is the most popular yes this
is from the aclu event i look way fire
in so many other pictures i'm showing
way more cleavage than so many other
pictures how is the most popular i
understand
it's the red you know what red does work
on me i won't lie red does work on me so
i'll take it in this time period
i let stylists tell me what to do a lot
and by that i mean i was constantly
uncomfortable
this dress is way too tight you can see
it right there in the picture my spanx
are in the indenting my back fat
so it is creating a crevice in my back
and i remember vividly not being able to
sit
or eat or drink and i'm like that's not
the life i want to live that's why i'd
be like this right now this is why i'm
look at me i can do jumping jacks right
now if i wanted to are you seeing this
this is the life i want to live i like
the way i dress
now better i think i'm more me i'm more
comfortable and if i'm going to get all
dolled up for events i want to have a
good time
you know i want to eat i want to drink i
want to go i want to go pee
this is too much to ask below are the
first three videos that come up when
searching lily singh on youtube and
sorted by most viewed
can you guess what they are definitely
my clubbing video with liza koshy is
going to be up here that's one
my video with zendaya and winnie harlow
my elevator video will should be up
there
then i'm going to say based on previous
slides that my youtube video with the
rock how to be a youtube star should be
up there those are my three guesses
boom boom zendaya winnie harlow i knew
it okay
that's for 48 million views dang
that video probably bought me a car
straight up really
i did not see that coming lele pons
what up 36 million views greek gods wow
that was a long time ago four years ago
dang okay what's the last one
i knew it i knew this is a classic a
classic video about clubbing what
clubbing is actually like with me and
liza which was a much anticipated collab
so i'm not shocked about that one at all
if you look also
we look very different just to work we
look very different i know we're both
brown and it's confusing but
i just wanna we don't look alike
so put that out there representation
matters y'all really did a lot of work
for this thank you
why my goodness we went on ebay and
found some of the least expensive and
most expensive items when searching lily
sing can you guess what they are
i can truthfully say i've never even
thought about this being a thing
and i hope none of this is creepy like a
strand of my hair i'm sure there's
something for 2.99
2.99 on ebay surrounding me i'm sure
most expensive i would like to hope at
least a hundred dollars i'd be okay with
being the most expensive thing that's
the minimum for me though it needs to be
at least 100.
oh wait this is the least expensive
thing
no no this is the most
whatever i didn't care um so this
there's a cardboard cutout of me that is
69. the expensive thing about me is 69.
also that numbers i can get further
roasted in the comments this is
horrible you go to whole foods and buy
one loaf of bread and it's 69
okay my god it's fine we're still hot
we're humble
this is an interesting choice though
because this is from an event
where i'm wearing a branded t-shirt so
there's just so many different
ways you could get sued here then the
least expensive thing okay 4 26 i said
2.99 so hey
this book is the book that is not
written by me
but very much so makes it seem like it's
written by me it's releasing the
unofficial superman guide by joe berry
joe let me talk to you real quick okay
boo listen to me when my book came out i
need you to know that this book
was the bane of my existence i'm sorry i
appreciate you i respect you but it was
the bit of my existence
because of the confusion it cost with my
book having said all of that
i sincerely hope from the bottom of my
heart that you have secured the bag
if i could give this to you in some way
i hope many people have bought this book
before 26
i hope you secured the bag joe mine's my
wish for you that's my wish for you
i just want to also say that cardboard
cutout says 30 day returns which further
breaks my heart because
on top of the 69 cardboard cutout now
there's a return policy says
you're not satisfied we'll give you a
not even
a store credit not even something that
shows some sort of commitment like an
exchange
a full refund okay we need to get out of
here
the end what did you think first of all
i'm i'm
utterly shook i really enjoyed learning
all of this
and i did not know a lot of this i'm not
gonna lie i strolled into this situation
i was like
they're showing me some stuff i don't
know all of them have to pretend like i
don't i don't know any of that
usually when things like winning teen
choice awards are being put on lists
press lists happen because i'm so busy i
don't fully take the moment to enjoy
those things
seeing how a lot of the spikes on the
chart were because of those moments i
was like oh
like that was a big moment i'm gonna say
that i'm gonna try my best
to enjoy those moments because they do
make they do matter
they matter